[Music]
the day you left
for marseille i drove to the airport
i went to the gift shop and i saw this
necklace
it was gold said still water on it
i thought it'd be a little piece of home
to take with you
[Music]
some folks are born
you're in marseille for occasion
i visit my daughter
the father of the girl hate the american
student
yes ma'am
allison came here for college and that's
where she met this girl
lina one night she family in the dead
and called the police
all they cared about was alison sleeping
with some arab girl i
loved her i know you did but everybody
thinks that i killed her
we have exhausted every possible legal
action is that a lawyer not helping you
i'm doing it myself for now i could have
what's your name william maya that's
nice
she's very protective with me
you seen that guy before no one would
talk to you trust me
i'm not from here it's not safe for you
she's my little girl god please
[Music]
i'm not going to give up
it will be a serious mistake to commit a
crime to prove your daughter
innocent it will not get her out of jail
and it will send you in lord
please keep your watchful eye on alison
amen
police did you ask her to lie i'm trying
to get my little girl out of jail that's
all i give a damn about
you sound very american right now good i
am
yeah and you're also a stranger here
what did you do
you just have to trust me
[Music]
you